We Begin the program in Ukraine who's
blaming Russia for shelling several
residential buildings in the southern
city of zaparisa this morning
the Region's Governor says two people
have been killed and Rescuers are still
digging out survivors from the rubble
let's go straight to our correspondent
who is live in zapparesia for us and I
believe you're actually outside that
residential building which was shell
down
yeah this is actually one of two
residential buildings that was hit at
around as we understand it far between
five and six in the morning I'm just
gonna step out here just to show you the
scale of the devastation uh the smoke
keeps on coming out rescue workers have
tried been trying to control this we've
been standing here for the past hour and
a half or so and there are fears that
the roof might collapse anytime soon and
I have to say as we were walking here I
mean the impact of this blast was felt
quite far away as window shops were
shattered on the ground Banks were
destroyed on the other side of the road
here there's a supermarket that's a
completely charred and this is just one
of two buildings that were hit here in
Zappa regia City this morning there's
also a private home that was hit and as
you said so far we know of two women who
were killed in these attacks but rescue
workers are telling us that they're
still trying to figure out if under such
trouble they might be other people now
this is the capital of the zaparita
region a region that just a few days ago
uh President Vladimir Putin has Annex
even though he holds only about 65
percent of this region and of late the
attacks on zaparita City have been
nearly on a daily basis people are
wondering uh what could happen next
certainly the message coming out of the
Kremlin is that all of the upper region
region should be a part of the Russian
Federation even though the borders
haven't been set yet and zaparita of
course where the nuclear power plant
Europe's largest is based what is the
latest around the security of that
well the the power plant is not in the
city it's quite a drive away across the
river uh now it is at the moment secure
as we understand it in the sense that
all six reactors have been uh shut down
a while ago
um but uh they are certainly there's
certainly shelling ongoing in the area
Russia accusing Ukraine Ukraine accusing
uh Russia uh now the uh the head of the
atomic International Atomic agency is
supposed to come to Ukraine after
visiting Moscow in the days to come top
of the agenda being the security of this
nuclear Farm because if something like
this happens there it could have
devastating effects Russia is saying
that it has appointed a new director to
that plan and to that plant and is
asking the ukrainians to help cooperate
keeping its secure but this is something
that does scare people here we've been
chatting with them throughout the past
few weeks about it our people have
bought their iodine tablets the
government is send has sent us issued
some guidelines about what to do or not
do in case of a leak coming out of that
nuclear plant and is also there's an app
for people to check on a daily basis
which shows the level of radiation at
the moment the level of radiation is in
the green so nothing suspect happening
but certainly when these missile attacks
happen targeting
residential buildings people might
wonder if that was on purpose or it was
by mistake and in that case could that
happen also to the nuclear plants indeed
incredibly worrying thank you for that
Abdul Hamid reporting that live from
zapparasia just outside where that
residential building was bombed